Mark your calendars, Keanu fans, because two
of Keanu Reeves' most anticipated new projects
are currently slated to hit theaters on the
very same day.
John Wick: Chapter 4 and the fourth Matrix
film will both debut on May 21, 2021, creating
a possible conundrum for moviegoers.
It's certainly an interesting choice for Warner
Bros. to settle on that specific release date
for The Matrix 4 when Summit Entertainment
and Lionsgate already claimed it for John
Wick: Chapter 4.
Unless audiences want to catch both on the
same day, they'll have to choose one flick
to see before the other.
"Woah."
Whether the studios are trying to encourage
a double feature or see which property is
more popular, May 21, 2021 will certainly
be a big day at the movies for Keanu fans.
Since it was announced in August 2019, fervor
has been building for the fourth Matrix film,
which marks the newest addition to the Wachowskis'
canon since the original trilogy concluded
in 2003 with Matrix: Revolutions.
So far, The Matrix 4 already has a star-studded
cast.
Helmed by Lana Wachowski and fronted by Reeves
as Neo and his Matrix co-star Carrie-Anne
Moss as Trinity, the cast will also include
Neil Patrick Harris, Jada Pinkett Smith, Mindhunter's
Jonathan Groff, and The Get Down standout
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
As for John Wick, the franchise kicked off
in 2014 with former Matrix stuntman Chad Stahelski
co-directing the film.
Thanks to mind-bending action and a standout
performance from Reeves as an expert assassin
pulled out of retirement following the death
of his dog, the first John Wick film was an
immediate hit.
It spawned two sequels John Wick: Chapter
2 and John Wick: Chapter 3 Parabellum . All
three films succeeded at the box office, and
the franchise as a whole has completely changed
the action genre.
Reeve's career renaissance has been a long
time coming.
After roles in varied projects like Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventure and an adaptation
of Bram Stroker's Dracula, Keanu dipped a
toe into full-fledged action films with Speed
in 1994.
Before long, the Wachowskis came calling with
The Matrix, and Reeves' career changed overnight
thanks to his role as Neo.
Throughout the original trilogy, Reeves cemented
himself as a bonafide star, but he had a few
rocky years that followed his Matrix success.
In the midst of Matrix mania and shortly thereafter,
Reeves made a string of poorly received films
like Sweet November, 47 Ronin, and The Watcher.
Though he appeared in critically acclaimed
projects like Richard Linklater's A Scanner
Darkly, nothing was quite as successful as
The Matrix franchise.
During his down time, Reeves stepped behind
the camera, making his directorial debut with
the underrated action flick, The Man of Tai
Chi, in 2013.
Luckily, Reeves found himself reconnecting
to the world of The Matrix when he reunited
with Chad Stahelski years later for the John
Wick series.
The franchise restored Reeves to his full
action glory.
Reeves insisted on doing most of his own stunt
work for the first film, which received glowing
reviews from critics and fans.
"People keep asking me if I'm back and I haven't
really had an answer, but yeah, I'm thinking
I'm back."
Thanks in large part to John Wick, Reeves
is firmly back on Hollywood's A-list, and
he remains as charming as ever.
A truly beloved celebrity for decades, he's
even found time to laugh at himself in between
his stone-faced role as John Wick.
In 2019, Reeves lampooned his own image in
Netflix's Always Be My Maybe, playing an over-the-top
version of himself in the charming romantic
comedy.
There's no denying that Reeves is once again
back at the top of his game, and is seemingly
better than he's ever been before.
It remains to be seen whether either Summit
and Lionsgate or Warner Bros. will stand down
and change the release date for either John
Wick or The Matrix 4 of the upcoming films,
but having both movies debut on May 21 of
that year might be a perfect opportunity to
celebrate all things Reeves.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.